these days kubernetes is getting a lot
of attention a research on using
containers found that 71% of respondents
were using kubernetes the definition of
kubernetes keeps changing as it keeps
growing communities is a container
management system developed by google in
2014 it is an open source portable
system for automatic container
deployment and management kubernetes
eliminates many of the manual processes
involved in deploying and scaling
containerized applications on that node
hi guys welcome to this complete
kubernetes course by simply learn in
this video we'll be covering some of the
most important concepts related to
kubernetes our trainers Mathieu and
cheese ananth who have over ten years of
experience in their walks will be
teaching us about kubernetes first we
will give an introduction to kubernetes
and learn how to install Kubuntu TS on
ubuntu then we dive deep into the
architecture of kubernetes look at some
use cases and understand the differences
between kubernetes and docker we will
then learn how to make abilities work on
AWS and finally we will look into some
of the most common kubernetes interview
questions so let us begin
Matthew our trainer has over 10 years of
experience in working with diverse
platforms and will take us through the
introduction and architecture of
kubernetes so let's jump into our first
section of life before kubernetes so the
way that you have done work in the past
where you may be doing work right now is
really building out and deploying
solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a data center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is deploying code
out to virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and you're
code isn't going to work effectively and
there may be issues with uptime and
errors within the infrastructure of your
entire environment there's going to be
problems with resource allocation and
you're gonna have air issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not look not effectively and not
load balanced and effectively across the
environment the problem that you have
with this kind of infrastructure is that
it gets very expensive how you are can
only install one piece of software on
one service on one piece of hardware so
your hardware is being massively
underutilized this is where virtual
machines have become really popular with
a virtual machine you're able to have
better resource utilization and
scalability at much less cost and this
allows you to be able to run multiple
virtual machines on a single piece of
hardware the problem is is that VMs or
virtual machines are not perfect either
some of the challenges you run with vm's
is that the actual hardware and software
needed needed to manage the VM
environment can be expensive there are
security risks with virtual with VMs
there are security risks with VMs there
have been data breaches recorded about
solutions that run in virtualized
environments you also run into an issue
of availability and this is largely
because you can only have a finite
number of virtual machines running on a
piece of hardware and this results in
limitations and restrictions in the
types of environment you want to be
running and then finally setting up a
managing a virtualized environment is
time consuming it can take a lot of time
and it can also get very expensive so
how about kubernetes well kubernetes is
a tool that allows you to manage
containerized deployment of solutions
and inherently kubernetes is a tool that
is really a next level maturity of
deployment so you can think of your
maturity curve as deploying code in
directly to hardware in a data center
and then deploying your solutions to
virtual machines the next ever
illusion of that deployment is to use
containers and kubernetes so let's kind
of go through and look at the
differences between a virtual machine
and kubernetes I've got a few here that
we want to highlight and you'll get an
understanding of what the differences
are between the two so first of all with
virtual machines there is inherently
security risks and what you'll find is
we get dig through the architecture
later and presentation is that
kubernetes is inherently secure um and
this is largely because of the legacy
code the legacy of kubernetes and where
it came from and we'll talk about that
in just a moment but kubernetes is
inherently secure virtual machines are
not easily portable now with that said
they they are technically portable
they're just not very easily portable
whereas with kubernetes it's working
with docker container soldiers it is
extremely portable that it means that
you can actually spin up and spin down
and manage your infrastructure exactly
the way that you want it to be managed
and scale it on the demands of the
customers as they're coming in to use
the solution from a time consuming point
of view kubernetes is much less time
consuming than with a virtual machine a
few other areas that we want to kind of
highlight from differences virtual
machines use much less isolation when
building out the encapsulated
environment then kubernetes does for
instance with a virtual machine you have
to run hypervisor on top of the OS and
hardware and then inside of the virtual
machine you also have to have the
operating system as well whereas in
contrast on a kubernetes environment
because it's leveraging a docker
container and/or container like
technologies it only has to have the OS
and the hardware and then inside of each
container doesn't need to have that
additional OS layer it's able to inherit
what it needs to be able to run the
application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible and allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of hardware than versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
hardware
so as we highlighted here VMs are not as
portable as kubernetes and kubernetes is
poor
directly related to the use of
containerization and because kubernetes
is built on top of containers it is much
less time-consuming because you can
actually script and automatic allocate
resource to nodes within your kubernetes
environments ism allows the
infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
why we are running into a social where
kubernetes had to come about because the
demand for having more highly scalable
solutions that are more efficient was
just really a natural evolution of this
software deployment model that started
with pushing out code to physical
hardware and then pushing code out to
virtual machines and then needing to
have a solution much more sophisticated
kubernetes would have come about at some
point in time I'm just really glad it
came back when it did so what is
kubernetes let's let's dig into the
history of kubernetes and how it came
about
so in essence kubernetes is an open
source platform that is allows you to
manage and deploy and maintain groups of
containers in the container is something
like darker and if you're developing
code you're probably already using
darker today consider kubernetes as the
tool that manages multiple docker
environments together now we talked a
lot about docker and as a container
solution with kubernetes the reality is
is that kubernetes can actually use
other container tools out there but dr.
just simply is the most popular
container out there both these tools are
open source that's why they're so
popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your solutions and they were
designed for the post digital world that
we live in existing today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
Google and the original project was
Google bought Google borg it does
exactly want kubernetes and does today
but kubernetes was rewritten from the
ground up and then released as an open
source project in 2014 so that people
outside of Google could take it
of the power of kubernetes
containerization management tools and
today it is managed by the cloud native
computing foundation and there are many
many companies that support and manage
kubernetes so for instance if you're
signing up for Microsoft Azure AWS
Google cloud all of them will leverage
kubernetes and it's just become the
de-facto tool for managing large groups
of containers so let's kind of step
through some of the key benefits that
you'd experience from kubernetes and so
we have nine key benefits and the first
it is highly portable it is 100% open
source code and this means that you can
actually go ahead and contribute to this
code project if you want to through
github the ability to scale up the
solution is incredible what's the the
history of kubernetes being part of a
Google project for managing the Google
network and infrastructure kind of
really sets the groundwork for having a
solution that is highly scalable the out
of the high scalability also comes the
need for high availability and this is
the desire to be able to have a highly
efficient and highly energized
environment that also you can really
rely on so if you're building out of
kubernetes management environment you
know that it's going to be available for
the solutions that you're maintaining
and it's really designed for deployment
so you can script out the environment
and actually have it as part of your
DevOps model so you can scale up and
meet the demands of your customer then
what you'll find is that the load
balancing is extremely efficient and it
allows you to distribute the load
efficiently across your entire network
so your network remains stable and then
also the tool allows you to manage the
orchestration of your storage so you can
have local storage such as an SSD on the
hardware that the kubernetes is meant
and maintaining or if the kubernetes
environment is pulling storage from a
public cloud such as asia or AWS you can
actually go ahead and make that
available to entire system and you can
inherit the security that goes back and
forth between the cloud environments and
one of things you'll find
with kubernetes is that it is designed
for a cloud first environment and
kubernetes as well is that it is really
a self-healing environment so if
something happens or something fails
kubernetes will detect that failure and
then either restart the process kill the
process or replace it and then because
of that you also have automated rollout
some drawbacks in case you need to be
able to manage the state of the
environment and then finally you have
automatic packaging so you can actually
specify the compute power that's being
used from CPM ramp for each container hi
guys
in today's video I am going to show you
how to install Ubuntu on communities
communities is an open source platform
used for deployment and management of
containers so let's get started
now the first step is to install the
necessary dependencies using two of the
commands first is sudo apt-get update
which gets all the updates
[Music]
and then you have to enter a password so
this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport HTTP this is basically
used to make repositories while HTTP so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt installed okaaay Oh
you have to choose white
and this will take a few minutes
you
okay that's that so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo systemctl
start oka and sudo systemctl and even
though
so now the Dockers anyway so now we are
done with the first step of installation
the next step is we have to install the
necessary components for communities
before that we have to install the curl
come on because one command is used to
send data using a URL syntax let's
install the curl command using the
command sudo apt-get install go
[Music]
so you have to select why and this will
take few minutes
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download an ad key for kubernetes
installation from a URL so let's go
ahead with that pseudocode
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo apt key ad
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using C or sudo chmod command
[Music]
okay so the bar machine has changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file this is a URL
save us
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to Subin it is
not list now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are gonna install
the kubernetes components that is
cubelet cubed Ian Q Bechtel and
kubernetes EMM so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap off
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that sudo swap off -
II now let's go ahead with the
initialization pseudo Q ADM in it this
is going to take a few minutes
you
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy instant
okay that's done so moving forward the
next step is to deploy paths using the
following command
you
now the pots have been deployed to a
network to see all the pots you have to
use the command sudo cubic to get false
[Music]
they concede the positive we keep
talking about containers but that's
really what kubernetes is all about it's
being how to manage your applications
managed through containers and being
able to do that in a virtualized
infrastructure and I think that's also
really good with the kubernetes it's
really easy to point solutions you just
have to use a simple curl call and you
can actually push out your kubernetes
infrastructure so let's have an overview
of the kubernetes architecture so
kubernetes is really broken up into
three key areas you have your work
session where you develop your commands
then you push out those commands to your
master and the master is comprised of
four key areas which essentially control
all of your note and the note contains
multiple parts and each pod has your
docker container built into it so
consider that you could have a really
almost an infinite number of pods a very
infinite number of nodes being managed
by the master environment so you have
your cluster which is a collection of
servers they maintain the availability
and the compute power such as RAM CPU
and disk utilization and you have the
master which is really components that
control and schedule the activities of
your network and then you have the node
which actually hosts the actual doctor
virtual machine itself and be able to
actually control and communicate back to
the master the health of that pod and
we'll get into more detail now sure to
take jelton later in the presentation so
hey you know you keep hearing me talk
about containers but they really are the
center of the work that you doing with
kubernetes and the concept around
kubernetes and containers is really just
a natural evolution of where we've been
with Internet and digital technologies
over the last 10 15 years
so before kubernetes you had tools where
you either run virtual machines or
you're running data centers that had to
maintain and manage and notify you of
any interruptions in your network
kubernetes is the tool that a G comes in
and helps address those interruptions
and manages them for you so the solution
to this is the use of containers so you
can think of containers as that natural
evolution
from you know 15 20 years ago you would
have written your code and posted it to
a data center more recently you probably
post your code to a virtual machine and
then move the virtual machine and now
you actually just work directly into a
container and everything is
self-contained and can be pushed out to
your environment and the thing that's
great about containers they're their
isolate environments very easy for
developers to work in them but it's also
really easy for operations teams to be
able to move a container into production
so let's kind of step in and back and
look at a competing product - kubernetes
which is docker swarm now one of the
things we have to remember is that
docker containers which are extremely
popular I'm built by the company
daughter and made open source and docker
actually has other products one of those
other products is docker swarm and
docker swarm is a tool that allows you
to be able to manage multiple containers
so if we look at some of the the
benefits of using docker swarm versus
kubernetes one things that you'll find
is that both tools have strengths and
weaknesses but it's really good that
they're both out there because it helps
keep they did really kind of justifies
the importance of having these kind of
tools so kubernetes was designed
originally from the ground up to be auto
scaling always booked a swarm isn't the
load balancing is automatic on docker
swarm whereas with kubernetes you have
to manually configure load balancing
across your nodes the installation for
docker swarm is really fast and easy I
mean you can be up and running within
minutes kubernetes takes a little bit
more time is a little bit more
complicated eventually you'll get there
I mean it's not like it's gonna take you
days and weeks but it's it is a tool
that's a when you compare the two doctor
swarms much easier to get up and running
now what's interesting is that
kubernetes is incredibly scalable and
it's you know that's its real strength
is its ability how strong clusters
whereas with docker swarm is Casa
strength isn't as strong when compared
to kubernetes now you compare it to
anything else on the market it's really
good so this is kind of a splitting
hairs kind of comparison but kubernetes
really does
the advantage here if you're looking at
the two compared to each other for
scalability and kubernetes was designed
for by Google to scale up and support
Google cloud network infrastructure they
both allow you to be able to stamp share
and storage volumes with Donkin you can
actually do it with any container with
that is managed by the docker swamp
whereas with kubernetes it manages the
storage with the pods and a pod can have
multiple containers within it but you
can't take it down to the level of the
container interestingly kubernetes does
have a graphical user interface for
being able to control and manage the
environment the reality however is that
you're likely to be using terminal to
actually make the controls and commands
to control your either docker swarm or
kubernetes environment and it's great
that it has a GUI and to get you started
but once you're up and running you're
gonna be using terminal window for those
fast quick administrative controls that
you need to make so let's look at the
hardware components for kubernetes so
what's interesting is that kubernetes is
extremely light of all the systems that
we're looking at it's extremely
lightweight its allows you to have you
compare it to like a virtual machine
which is very heavy it you know
kubernetes is extremely lightweight and
how they uses any resources at all
interesting enough is that if you are
looking at the usage of CPU it's better
to actually take it for the cluster as a
whole rather than individual nodes
because the nodes word should combine
together to give you that whole compute
power again this is why kubernetes works
really well in the cloud where you can
do that kind of activity rather than if
you're running in your own data center
so you can have persistent volumes such
as a local SSD or you can actually
attach to a cloud data storage again
kubernetes is really designed for the
cloud I would encourage you to use cloud
storage wherever possible rather than
relying on physical storage the reason
being is that if you connect to cloud
storage and you need to flex your your
storage the cloud will do that for you I
mean that's just an inherent
of why you'd have kind of storage
whereas if you're connecting to physical
storage you are always restricted to the
limitations of the physical hardware so
that's done kind of pivot and look at
the software components as compared to
the hardware components so the main part
of the component component is the actual
container and all of the software
running and the container runs on Linux
of you have documents stored as develop
on your machine it's actually running
inside of Linux that's what makes it so
lightweight and really one of these that
you'll find is that most data centers
and cloud providers now are running
predominantly on Linux inside IBM the
container itself is then managing side
of a part and a part is really just a
group of containers bundled together and
then the kubernetes scheduler and proxy
server with an adding manage what how
the pods are actually pushed out into
your kubernetes environment they are the
pods themselves can actually then share
resources both networking and storage so
the pods aren't pushed out manually
they're actually managed through a layer
of abstraction and part of their
deployment and and this is the strength
of kubernetes you used you define your
infrastructure and then kubernetes will
then manage you for you and there isn't
that problem of manual management of
pods if you have to manage the
deployment of them and you that's simply
taken away and it's completely automated
and the the final area of software
services is on ingress and this is
really the secure way of being able to
have communication from outside of the
cluster and passing of information into
that classroom and again this is done
security through SSL layers and allows
you to ensure that security is at the
center of the work that you have within
your kubernetes environment so let's
dive now into the actual architecture
before we start looking at use case of
how kubernetes is being employed so
kubernetes again is we looked at this
diagram at the beginning of the
presentation and there are really three
key areas there's the workstation where
you develop your commands and then you
have your master environment which
controls the scheduling communication
and the actual commands that you have
created and pushes those out and manages
the health of your entire node network
and each node has various pods so we
like break this down so the master node
is the most vital component with the
master you have four key control 0 etc
controller manager schedule and API
server the cluster store etc this ecchi
measured the details and values that
you've developed on your local
workstation and then we'll work with the
outlet control scheduling pie server to
communicate that out those instructions
of how your infrastructure should look
like to your entire network the control
manager is really an API server and
again this is all about security so we
use restful api which can be packaged in
ssl to communicate back and forth across
your pods and the master and indeed the
services within each of them as well so
at every single layer abstraction the
communication is secure the schedule as
the name would imply really schedules
and when tasks get sent out to the
actual nodes themselves by the nodes
themselves are done nodes they just have
the applications running on them the
master in the scheme is really doing all
of the work to make sure that your
entire network is running efficiently
and then you have the API server which
has your rest commands in the
communication back and forth across your
network so that is secure and efficient
so your node environment is where all
the work that you do with your
containers gets pushed out to so a work
is really a it's a combination of
containers in each container will then
logically run together on that node so
you'd have a collection of containers on
a node that all banking logical sense to
have together within each node you have
docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
you have your cubelet which is a service
for convenient information back and
forth to the service about the actual
health of the kubernetes node itself and
then finally you have the proxy server
and the proxy server is able to manage
the nodes the volumes the decree
new containers and actually helps pass
the communique they be held off Dana
back up to the master to see whether or
not the containers should be either
killed stop started or updated so
finally let's look at see where
kubernetes is being used by other
companies so you know kubernetes is
being used by a lot of companies and
they're really using it to help manage
complex existing systems so that they
can have greater performance and with
the end goal of being able to delight
the customer increase value to the
customer and enhance increased value and
revenue into the organization so an
example of this is a company called
Blackrock where they actually went
through the process of implementing
kubernetes so they could so Blackrock a
node challenge where they needs to be
able to have much more dynamic access to
their resources they were running
complex installations on people's
desktops and it was just really really
difficult to be able to manage their
entire infrastructure so they actually
went and pivoted to using communities
and this allowed them to be able to be
much more scalable and expansive in the
management of their infrastructure and
as you can imagine kubernetes was then
hooked into their entire existing system
and has really become a key part of the
success that Blackrock is now
experiencing of a very stable
infrastructure and the bottom line is
that it's Blackrock is now that able to
have confidence in their infrastructure
and be able to give buy confidence as
back to their customers through the
implementation and more rapid deployment
of additional features and services so
let's have a look at some of the
companies using kubernetes there are a
lot and if you're doing any work today
in the cloud and you're even if you're
just starting up and doing some simple
exam and there's a really good chance
that you are using kubernetes but some
of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised and using
kubernetes are Spotify sa P a Bey and of
course some of the the big companies out
there Google with their entire network
of solutions and Microsoft with office
and their tools so let's take a step
into a you but now let's have a look at
a kubernetes use case
and in this example we're gonna look at
the New York Times and how they use
kubernetes to solve a problem that their
IT department was struggling with so
when New York Times started working
after their data centers there their
actual deployments were small and the
applications were managed across VMs but
the problem is is that as the New York
Times became more of a digital company
they started building more digital
solutions and at some point they
realized that what they needed to do was
to embrace the cloud and move all their
solutions to the cloud
however their first step of using the
cloud and this is I think typical for a
lot of companies is that they treated 8
the cloud hosted provider in the same
way as they would with a data center and
they at some point they realized they
had to take a change and this is where
the development team that came in and
they said look how about we stop
thinking of our solutions as a data
center even though they were being run
in Amazon I start thinking them as cloud
first solutions and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using Google cloud platform with
kubernetes as service and to provide
greater efficiency and so by using
communities they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
Susan's at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time but
uptime for the actual infrastructure
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you do the deployments it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the New York Times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do solutions through a more
traditional ticket based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
New York Times website so this finally
kind of looking to some of the important
terminologies before we take our time to
do a demo so we have six times that
we're going to
and we'll let you read through this but
we have a cluster which is a set of
machines fiscal vertical in which
applications are managed and run we have
a node that are the work of machines
that run containerize applications and
other workloads there is the pod which
is within a node and is a group of
containers that have deployed together
on the same host we have replication
controllers a replication controller is
used to define a paused lifecycle rather
than to create the pods directly we have
a selector which is an expression merged
label to filter specific resources
labels are key value pairs are attached
to objects such as pods and the key
value pair or the label can be filter
organized and perform operations on
resources replication sense define how
many replicas of each pod will be
running and managed when you want to
either replace a pod when it dies
annotation is a label with much larger
data capacity a name is a resource as it
is identified volume is the directory
which data is accessible to a container
namespaces provide additional
qualification to resources name and then
finally service in an abstraction of a
top tier pods which provide a single IP
address and dns name well which the pods
can be accessed so at this time what we
want to do is take you through
kubernetes demo that you runs through
some of these basic controls so I'm
going to take you through a video of how
to actually install kubernetes and to
use some of the basic instructions so
kubernetes is the most probably put used
platform for container management the
first step is to achieve install the
necessary dependencies so let's see if
there's any updates first so the first
so to check that there's any updates we
use the command sudo at - get update
when we enter in our password and this
looks like it's going to take a few
minutes because we've got a few updates
that need to be running all right we're
done all right next we're going to write
sudo apt-get install - y apt - transport
- HTTP and this will install all the
dependencies we need trechie start
installing the solutions needed for
kubernetes
that was quick now we're gonna put in
the docket dependency and the way we do
that is write the command sudo apt
install Daugherty Oh typo correct that
quickly and put it in Y so the yes
continue and it's going to take a while
because we're going to download install
docker off the internet and it's quite a
large installation now it'd be good time
to go get a cup of coffee because it'll
take us about a minute to get this all
done once we actually have doctor
installed we'll let you go ahead and
we'll start docker and the naval Dhaka
using our pseudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start in a bold darker we're going to
using so they use sudo systemctl start
ducking and sudo systemctl enable danke
this will be quite quick so the next
step is to install all the components
for Cuban unities and we're going to
install the curl command and then Cuba
let's cube C and then cube ADM we're
going to install all the necessary tools
we'll do the curl command cube let's
cubic c2 and cube ADM and so let's go
ahead and put in the sudo apt - get
installed curl I'm gonna get a prompt
you can say yes for that and then after
this we'll go ahead and install
kubernetes so the first what we're gonna
do is we're gonna actually put in the
kubernetes key so that's gonna be sudo
curl - s and then we have a long URL
which is HTTP packages or cloud
google.com
apt dark apt - key GPG sudo apt - key
there we go
click my type over there okay now we
have to go ahead and change permissions
of like folder so we do that with sudo
CH mo d 777 slash etc slash apt
sources.list dot d alright we're good
okay now you want to go ahead and open
up your text editor and we're gonna make
an actual edit and we're going to create
a simple file and so what we are typing
is the following command d b HC g bt apt
- kubernetes dot io / kubernetes -
xenial main and we're gonna save this
file in the etc folder and then look for
and then apt just commute down a little
bit and there we have it and we're gonna
save it in the apt - get updates and
we're gonna name this file as kubernetes
dots list and we'll save that and then
we can close out then no pad and go back
to the terminal window and let's look
and see if there are any updates
again so we're gonna go ahead and run
apt-get update and it's going
run any updates from what we've created
and we want to check what's in the
folder and so we do cat slash except et
et Cie such apt such sources dot this
dot d such kubernetes dot list and there
we are it shows what we have in that
text file and so we're gonna go ahead
and we're going to install cubelet cubic
cubic to and q ATM but first we're gonna
have to initialize the master I'm going
to show you it what you an error you
would get if you were to install cubelet
and the other files too quickly you get
the fine era
we have installed cubelet QB a DM cube
actor Thank You Bonetti CNI and so we'll
go ahead and use sudo swap - - a and now
we're going to initialize the Massa note
how we get to that with sudo cube ADM in
it and this will take a few minutes for
to initialize
that's all done alright so we're going
to deploy the pod to a network and we
have to come on so we're going to use we
use sudo cube root cube CTL apply and
then we were a long path work to type
out which is - F HTTP raw github can
content calm
coreos flannel master documentation cube
- file dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're gonna do that by creating
mmk TR Dash P and then we have dollar
sign home - cube create that new
directory and sudo CP - I and then the
path will be etc - kubernetes admin dot
conf and then da sign home slash cubed
slash config and then final one will be
sudo CH o WN DOS I'm I've been praying I
D - you closed paren colon dollar sign a
brand ID / - G close paren door sign
home slash dot q / config alright now
we're going to go ahead and deploy and
let's see oh yeah I think I have a typo
my command here yep oh yes I did have a
typo and so I've got that incorrect now
so documentation is such a spell the T
not in this and then we're gonna go
ahead and we're going to put in the next
line just sudo cubic cube CTL apply - f
and then we're just gonna change a
little bit of the actual link here and
that runs great and now we want to be of
see all of the pods that we have in our
network and so we're gonna do that by
writing the command sudo Kubik CEO TCL I
get pods - or all - - namespaces and it
should list all of our puds we only have
one there we are it's all of our content
now we're going to so there's only one
notes let's see what we have here so
we're gonna use come on sudo you know
cubic TL get nerds there we are just one
node so our final step is to actually go
ahead and deploy a service and so what
we're gonna go ahead is deploy the NGI
and exit service and we're gonna do that
with the command sudo cubic CTL run - -
image equals n GI and X and we're going
to put this into port 80 so it's going
to be and
- app - - port equals 80 - - environment
EMV equals a wound Cohen open quotes a
domain equals cluster close quotes
and we're gonna write one more come on
which is pseudo cube CTL exposed
deployments ngi next - app - - port
equals 80 - - name equals ng INX - HTTP
and once we've done this we will be able
to then run the command - ecchi see our
services and they'll be quite a few of
them and our final command is sudo
docker PS - eh anyway quite a lot of
lists quite a lot of services listed so
there you are that's the instructions on
how to get docker up and running and
with some basic commands and it is worth
going through a few times to again get
right but once you actually have to the
kubernetes where I'm up and running and
managing your document environment in
containers it's extremely powerful
kubernetes vs darker so let's go through
a couple of scenarios as to one for
kubernetes and then one for docker and
we can actually go through and
understand what the problems specific
companies have actually had and how
they're able to use the two different
tools to solve them so our first one is
with bows and bows had a large catalog
of products that kept growing and their
infrastructure had to change so the way
that they looked at that was actually
establishing two primary goals to be
able to allow their product groups to be
able to easier more easily catch up to
the scale of their business so after
going through a number of solutions they
ended up coming up with a solution of
having kubernetes running their iot
platform as a service inside of Amazon's
AWS cloud service and what you'll see
with both these products is they're very
cloud friendly but here we have bows and
kubernetes working together with AWS to
be able to scale up and meet the demands
of their product catalog and so the
result is that we were able to increase
the number of non production deployments
significantly by taking the number of
services from being large bulky services
down to small micro services being able
to handle as many as 1250 and plus
deployments every year an incredible
amount of time and value has been
open through the use of kubernetes now
let's have a look at darker and see what
a similar problem that people would have
so the problem is with PayPal and PayPal
and processes something in the region of
over two hundred payments per second
across all of their products and PayPal
doesn't just have paper they have
Braintree and venmo so the challenge
that PayPal was really being given is
that they had different architectures
which resulted in different maintenance
cycles and different deployment times
and overall complexity from having a
decades-old architecture with PayPal
through to a modern architecture with a
venmo through the use of docker paper
was able to unify the application
delivery and be able to centralize the
management of all of the containers with
one existing group the net net result is
that paper was able to migrate over 700
applications into doggit enterprise
which consists of over 200,000
containers this ultimately opened up a
50% increase in availability for being
able to in a DIN additional time for
building testing and deploying of
applications just a huge win for PayPal
now let's dig into kubernetes and darker
as the kubernetes is an open source air
platform and it's designed for being
able to maintain a large number of
containers and what you're gonna find is
that your argument for kubernetes versus
darker isn't a real argument its
kubernetes and darker working together
so kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and docker
is the number one container management
solution and so with docker you're able
to automate the deployment of your
applications being able to keep them in
a very lightweight environment and being
able to create a nice consistent
experience so that your developers are
working in the same containers that are
then also pushed out to production so
with dr you're able to manage multiple
containers running on same hardware much
more efficiently than you are with a vm
environment
and the productivity around docker is
extremely high you're able to keep your
applications very isolated the
configuration for document easy you can
be up and running in minutes with docker
once you have it installed and running
on your development machine or inside of
your DevOps environment so we look at
the deployment between the two and the
differences are Cuba Nettie's is really
designed for a combination of pods and
services in its deployment
whereas with docker it's around about
deploying surfaces in containers so the
difference here is that kubernetes is
going to manage the entire environment
and then and that environment consisting
of pods and inside of a pod you're gonna
have all of your containers that you're
working on and those containers are can
control the services that actually power
the applications that are being deployed
kubernetes is by default an auto scaling
solution has it turned on and is always
available whereas docker does not and
that's not surprising because docker is
a tool for building out solutions
whereas kubernetes is about managing
your infrastructure kubernetes is going
to run health checks on the liveness and
readiness of your entire environment so
not just one container but tens of
thousands of containers
whereas docker is going to limit the
health check to the services that it's
managing within its own containers now
I'm not going to kid you cubed --'tis is
quite hard to set up it's of the tools
that you will be using in your DevOps
environment isn't it's not an easy setup
for you to use and for this reason you
want to really take advantage of the
surfaces within asher and other similar
cloud environments where they actually
will do the setup for you Dokka in
contrast is really easy to set up you
can as I mentioned earlier you can be up
to running in a few minutes as you would
expect the fault tolerance within
kubernetes is very high and this is by
design because the architecture of
kubernetes is built on the same
architecture that Google uses for
managing its entire cloud infrastructure
in contrast docker has lower fault
tolerance but that's because it's just
managing the the surfaces within its own
containers what you'll find is that most
public cloud providers will fight
support for both kubernetes and docker
here we've highlighted Microsoft Azure
because they were very quick to jump on
and support kubernetes but the realities
is that today Google Amazon and many
other providers asked having first level
support for kubernetes has just become
extremely popular in a very very short
timeframe the companies using both
kubernetes and docker is fast and every
single day there are more and more
companies using it and you should be
able to look and see whether or not you
can add your own company to this list
thanks Matthew
now we have two Danone who will take us
through a demo to set up kubernetes on
AWS with cops so what our orchestration
tools the application development and
lifecycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has the requirement
that it has in terms of the hardware the
features of fault tolerance self-healing
capabilities auto scaling all this as
complicated over the last few years as a
part of DevOps one thing that everyone
is interested in is managing all this
application dependency or lifecycle
management using some or the other kind
of a tool so that's where these
orchestration tools have become very
very popular so what kind of features
that they provide is you will have to
just let them know what are the kinds of
tool sets that is required what are the
fault tolerance mechanisms that it has
to be adopted to what kind of a
self-healing capabilities that
application will have to need and if at
all there is any auto scaling features
that is required if at all you can bake
in all these specific parameters into
your tool your orchestration tool
becomes a one-stop shop for all your
deployment and configuration management
needs that's where this orchestration
tools have become a very very popular
and relevant specifically these days
when people are more and more
interested in adopting DevOps practices
alright so having said that about
orchestration tools let's concentrate on
two of these orchestration tools
specifically for container management
docker swarm and kubernetes many of the
applications that are written for these
kind of containers are called our kind
of fall into a category of cloud native
where the application need not know much
about the underlying infrastructure or
the platform where these applications
are running so these two along with
Apache me sauce there are many other
container management systems but I'm
gonna pick docker swamp and kubernetes
for comparing the features that is
provided by these two frameworks for the
sake of comparison I picked up docker
swarm and Coburn des just because of the
reason that both of them operate in the
space of container management they do
something very very similar to
containers that is the similarity that
exists between these two orchestration
tools however there's a big difference
that exist when it comes to the types of
containers that both of them cater to
and also the capacity of workloads they
can be used for docker swarm is a
cluster management solution that is
provided by docker container docker is
one of the very very popular containers
of recent times and in case you have
your applications that is totally
powered by only docker containers if you
have a need where you want to run a
cluster of servers which are running
only docker containers docker swarm
should be your choice for your
orchestration to kubernetes on the other
hand can cater to any other types of
containers other than docker and
including docker as well so in case you
have your applications which have got
docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they've got LX in them or any
other type of container kubernetes
should be a choice of orchestration to a
docker swarm can manage up to 40 50 or
60 max are nodes so in case your
application is totally written in docker
containers and the load or the expected
cluster size is about 50 60 nodes locust
swarm should be a choice of
orchestration tool on the other hand
kubernetes is some
that was open sourced by Google and the
kind of the scale of operations that
communities can cater to is Google scale
so if in case your applications are more
than a thousand nodes that is where
kavadis comes into play that's the big
difference that exists between Daka
swarm and communities putting those
differences aside let me compare locust
warm and covered is based upon other
features which are similar in nature the
first an important feature that
kubernetes provides is something called
as Auto scaling if at all the load on
your cluster is too high and your
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new VMs or
new nodes if at all you do that
configuration correctly kubernetes has
got the capacity or does got the feature
where it can bring up a new node and add
it to the cluster on the fly based upon
the load that exists at that moment on
similar lines if at all the load is not
too high it can identify few of those
nodes which have got less number of
replicas or less number of application
containers running on it it can move
them to some other node and also scale
down by deleting few notes from your
cluster so that is the powerfulness of
auto scaling
which is provided by communities and
this unfortunately does not exist in
Rocker swamp the other feature of load
balancing specifically application load
balancing so dr. swarm gives you an
application level auto load balancing
however kubernetes gives you the
flexibility of manually configuring any
other type of load balancer of your
choice for application load balancing
installation as I mentioned earlier
docker swarm is a loose cluster of
containers which are running on nodes it
is very easy to spin up a new node and
then connect them to a swarm and this
can be done in a very very loosely
coupled way where you can create swarms
of your choice nodes are allowed to
connect to swarms and quit or leave this
forms on the fly so in and all the
installation is pretty easy and
couple days on the other hand the
configuration of Covanta is the way to
spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the known how many must have
known so many conflict planes that you
want how many nodes that you want it's a
pretty tough thing to bring up a
kubernetes scalability
cover this strength is very very strong
they are very tightly coupled and even
they have the capability where on the
cluster size things or the nodes can be
increased on the fly based upon the
requirement on a docker swarm the
cluster strength is weak as compared to
co-produce worker nodes can be added to
a swamp
what converge can be asked to leave us
for more can be taken out of a swarm
based upon the requirement so this is
kind of a loosely coupled architecture
for docker swamp while cobalt is the
trustor is very tightly coupled since
docker swarm runs only docker containers
containers find it very easy to share
data and lot of other things with each
other because they all have the same
signature they are all from the same
family so it's very easy for them to
share not just volumes but a lot of
other things
however for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if your
application has to share some data
across different containers a little bit
of a complexity in how you would want
your containers to share data also when
it comes to kubernetes communities
groups containers in something called as
pods while a pod can have either one
container that's the preferred choice or
multiple containers and the idea of pod
is like each pod can run in any other
node it's not guaranteed that you would
want to have two or three pots to be
running on the same note that makes data
sharing a little bit of a different
thing compared to dogs form aha GUI so
there's not a good enough UI tool in
Dockers for at least the sea edition of
it which will allow you to get to know
what is running on your containers what
is the size of the containers what is
the volume of the containers and all
that stuff there are some free and
open-source tools like container which
gives you a good visibility into your
running docker containers however
there's nothing at a swarm level that is
provided by docker
kubernetes gives you an out-of-the-box
dashboard which is easy to configure and
set up you can also Club
with some matrix services and he can
also get information about the size of
the cluster that is running what is the
load on the nodes and stuff like that
all this across your cluster in a very
beautiful dashboard perspective so that
way this is little bit of a good UI for
kubernetes - raucous form it isn't
anything that is provided out of the box
we get to the demo section of my
tutorial now that you guys are aware as
to what is cobalt is what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node you probably
you're thinking that is pretty pretty
hard to kind of set this up so let me
demystify that by running you with a
quick demo of how to set up a simple
three node kubernetes cluster using a
tool called crops and I will be doing
this whole setup on my AWS cloud okay so
what is cops cops is nothing but a
simple truth is an admin tool that
allows you to bring up production grade
our coldest environments as I said
sitting up a couple disk cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why I would use something called as a
cops and I will use this on my cluster
which I'll spin up on my AWS instance so
have any W sub down and what I will do
first is I will first spin up an ec2
server I will power this with one of the
Linux a.m. eyes and I will install cops
on it now this will be my starting point
from where I'm going to trigger running
up a big cluster in our case I'll try to
keep it little small I don't want too
many notes in my truster I'm going to
have one master node and two worker
nodes this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know AWS is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what I
would do is I will create an I am role
which will attach to my ec2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configure
that I'm going to specify alright so
once I have my cluster set up I will
also install Cuba CTL which you'd
probably know by now is nothing but the
command-line utility using which I can
kind of connect to my cluster do some
jobs put some parts and stuff like that
so i will use cuba CTL i will also have
a pair of ssh keys so that from this
machine i would be able to successfully
get on to the master node and submit
jobs on my behalf so let me begin by
first logging into my AWS account all
the steps that i will be following to
bring up my AWS trustor Governors
cluster will be documented and I'll be
sharing you this document in a github
repository so that in case anybody wants
to try it be more than happy to find all
the required instructions in one place
ok now the first thing that I would need
is to launch an AWS ec2 instance now
this is an instance where I am going to
install cops and they will use it as a
base server from where I'm going to
fight some commands which will bring up
my cover this cluster so let me log in
to my AWS account and let me stick to
one particular region and let me bring
up some a1 ec2 instance alright so let
me launch my instance let me choose
doesn't matter in the ways but in case
you wanna try it on your free tire I
would recommend choose free tire only
and choose an ami of your choice let me
choose this instance I will make it t2
micro that is good for me configuration
instance details alright
I don't wanna change anything here that
looks good maybe I will change this 30
cake that's good for me like may I add a
tag to my instance I'll name this as my
cops server all right I would need a
bunch of approach to be opened up so
what I will do is I will create a new
security group called open to the world
I would not recommend that you do this
since I don't want to it will take a
long time for me to specifically pick
and choose the ports that has to be open
for running my cluster I don't want to
do that I will open up all the HTTP and
HTTPS ports so that is quicker
so I will say rtcp I would say from
anywhere just to be on the safe side
also connect to TP and HTTP and I make
this anywhere and anywhere this is good
for me I would say review on launch
alright so I chose RT to micro instance
just for the sake of easiness I opened
up all the ports and the instant details
are you've seen what is that have chosen
all right now important part is like I
would need a cheaper I need to create a
new keeper I will call this simply learn
keys I will download this cheaper and
then I will launch the instance it will
take some time for my ec2 instance to
come up in the meanwhile what I will do
is I will convert I have this PEM file
which is the pair of keys
SSH keys with which I need to login to
my ec2 instance so I need to convert
this because I'm trying to connect from
a Windows box I would need to convert
this into a PPK file
so have petition I'm going to load my
set of keys here and convert that tree
into a pivot entry all right all right I
would say save and save private key yes
I would say is simply learned or simply
fry weight by weight key I don't see
this here done that that's all so this
is my public key which is the PEM file
and this is my typical or my private key
now using the private key I will login
to my ec2 instance okay now my ec2
instances up and running it is running
in this oh hi oh region and this is the
IP address of my public appearance of my
machine so let me connect to it so I use
MOBA X term which is nothing but an ssh
emulator you can use putty or any of
these sessions which are allow you to do
an ssh this is my IP address of my
machine and the since F spun up and
Amazon am I the user this is the default
user I would need to specify the private
keys for my session and this is the
private key for my session okay I am in
my Amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that I need to
do alright so as I said I just brought
up my ec2 instance
but I would need my ec2 instance to run
few things on my behalf so that it can
spin up easy to other ec2 instances it
can also talk to an s3 bucket where I'm
going to store the instant state of my
company's cluster also some sort of an
auto scaling group because I want to
spend up more and more instances I also
want to have a private hosted zone using
my route 53 so I would need my ec2
instance to have all these sort of
permissions for my server so what I
would do is I will go and create a
permission a role in the ec2 I rather in
the AWS I am role and I'll attach this I
am role to my easy to instance for it so
let me go to my I am which is nothing
but the identity and access management
I'll create a rule called as possibly
cops phone I will create a role this
role will be used by my ec2 so I'm gonna
click on ec2 I'll say next permissions
they would need a lot of permissions
specific permissions to be very honest
and the permissions are all listed out
here
s3 ec2 and all this stuff just to keep
it really simple what I would do is I'll
create a role with the magnetic axis all
right so I don't want it tags and review
I'll create a role name I will say cops
for for ec2 all right so I'm going to
create a rule which has got
administrative access rules I'm going to
create a role so this would ensure that
my ec2 instance from which I'm going to
run my cluster would have all the
prerequisite permissions so that it can
go and spin up instances doc to his
three buckets and all that stuff alright
now let us have our running instance get
powered by this role so I will connect
this role to my running instance alright
so this is my easy to instant that is
running so action attach attach attach
attach replace I am roles so there is no
rule as of now I would want my cops on
hold for this it was the role that it
created so I want this new rule to be
assigned to my EC - all right great now
my ec2 instance which is my cop server
has got all the required permissions so
that he can create a cluster on my
behalf great now before this let me do a
sudo yum update - why so that any of the
PI because this is a newly provisioned
I just wanna ensure that all my library
system libraries are all updated so that
when I do install cop and keep CTL and
all those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or packing
issues so I'm just running a pseudo
update - why so that all the libraries
are updated ok looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and install cops cops is
a pretty simple installation it is
available in a particular location I
have to just copy this and ensure that I
do a curl and I install this particular
stuff alright so it is fetching the cops
tool it's installing for me once it is
copied down let me change the mood so
that I can execute it and then also let
me move it to my user local pin so that
it is available for me in my path ok
that's pretty much the cops installation
let me also do one other thing let me
you install something called as QB city
our so this is what would be you know a
tool using which I want to be firing my
commands to my cue ball this cluster
once it comes up this is pretty smaller
executable so city yeah alright so have
cheaper CTL as well as cops installed on
my easy to server now ok now what I'll
do next is I'm going to create an s3
bucket in AWS so that the equipment is a
cluster state is persisted in this
bucket so let me create a simple bucket
with this name s3 bucket with this name
so let me go to s3 and let me create a
simple bucket with this name I will just
say create a bucket okay so the simply
learn what kubernetes is the bucket that
I created so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
go and create a DNS entry or a DNS zone
or an AWS route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know I can give a cluster name for my
cupboard is cluster that I'm coming up
so I will create a private hosted zone
and possibly TE possibly I will call
this as simply learn dot n so this will
be my name of my private hosted zone in
case you already have any other public
hosted zones in your name you can always
put a route 53 hosted so on specific for
your domain name since I don't have
anyone I'm just gonna create a simple
private hostage zone so let me head down
to route 53 click on any of these and
you'll get this hosted zones out here so
I'm going to create a hostage down here
I'm going to create a hostage zone click
on create hosted zone um this would be
simply London I want to create a public
no I don't want public I want a private
hosted zone and I'm going to associate
my BBC ID for this hosted zone since I'm
gonna try out all my exercises in the
ohio region i will associate the BBC of
the ohio region for this right so this
is the one that is specific to the ohio
region so i will say this one i'll say
create a hosted so great now let me come
back to my easter box my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to go ahead with the installation of my
cluster only few things that I need to
take care of is that you know now that I
put our name for my cluster I also have
an s3 bucket that are configured for my
cluster I will have to ensure that I
need to put in these two configurations
as a part of my cluster building
activity so I will open my bash RC file
and I'm going to export these two
variables if at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is nothing but the
public or sorry the private hosted zone
that I created and the s3 bucket where
I'm going to create or rather I'm gonna
store my cluster state so let me copy
these two and open up my bash RC file
alright so I will just add these two and
copy these and export them out as my are
variable I'm gonna save this year now
let me ensure that this gets picked up
alright I've got these two that have
configured and I've also ensure that
this environment variables are set now
let me create a pair of SSH keys this is
to ensure that I can log in to the box
that I'm going to be provisioning as a
part of my cluster SSH - qijin I don't
want to give any parameters let it go to
the home directory with the default name
and without any buzz phrase alright so I
created a bunch of my keeper now I'm all
set to coil and run my cops a cops will
ensure that this will take some time for
the cluster to come up but this is a
actly how I would define my cops command
how are you I have copied here so cops
create cluster the state of the cops
cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what IO
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all I don't special is in
configuration for specifying the master
or the control pin as well if I don't
specify that the default one is one so
I'm going to create one primary or the
master node and two worker nodes size of
my master not size of the worker nodes
are what are the zones where I want this
to be created and where do I store the
cluster information and I've already
added this must account this is actually
not required but this is the command
that I'm going to fire off so that I
bring up my cluster all right that went
off very fast but this actually did not
create a cluster it is just the
definition of a cluster and that's why
this came out very fast now that
everything looks good for with whatever
configuration that I specified now let
me go ahead and create the cluster by
saying corpse
update cluster - - yes now this will
take some time are good five to ten
minutes for it no because this will
actually start provisioning the service
and as I mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration I'm going to come up with
one host a server and two nodes or these
worker nodes alright so this is the
command for me to validate the cluster
and I'm gonna try it out first and
please sure that you'll feel because all
my servers are not up yet it is taking
some time with the validation everything
failed but let me try to look at my ec2
instances and see how many servers do I
have running as of now if you see I had
only one server that had started which
was my cop server and automatically the
other three instances one is called
Northstar simply not in this these two
are the nodes and this is the master
node so these three got automatically
provision by the cops command that I ran
alright so this may take a while for it
to get validated a good fight attainment
so what I'll do is I'll pause the video
now and I'll come back once on the
server the cluster is up and running
it's been a good eight nine minutes sir
since I started my
cluster so let me validate now okay
seems good so there's a master node
minimum one max one some nodes which are
nothing but the slave nodes or the
worker nodes there are two of them due
to micro subnet
so my clusters seem to be up and running
and my cluster name is similar not in so
what I would want to do is now let me
just log into the master and see if I
can run some BOTS so let me get back to
my instalay installation steps here the
were rich and rush was done so let me
log in to my since my cluster name is
simple non dot and this is the way to
log into my box so let me get into my
box so if you see here this is the
hostname just the machine that I'm
currently in if you see this this is
nothing but our this cop server this is
a seventh now from here I'm trying to
get into the master box alright
so if you see the IP address has changed
I was in a different box I'm a different
box now if I see e hostname you'll find
a different host name so this is 153 or
just nothing but they must don't know
yeah that's 153 this is the particular
house so I'm getting into this machine
now so I started the cluster from my cop
server here it ran and brought up three
notes so I'm actually getting into my
master node and see if I can run some
bots on it alright so let me try coop
CTL and get cluster info try cube CTL
from get nodes alright so there are
three nodes here master node and one
master known and to vocal nodes so let
me see if I have some pots here q CL get
pods so there's no bonus of now so what
I'll try to do is let me just spin up a
very very simple part just to check if
my connections is everything is correct
or not correct I have a simple node.js
application that have built on about a
container for that this is already
pushed to the docker hub register it is
called simply run docker hub and the
image name that I have here is called my
node app and I will use this image to
power one of my pots that I will run so
this is the way in which I'm going to
launch my pod it will show you these
commands cube CTL I run the name for my
deployment that I'm going to run - I
have an image and this is the image that
is going to be powering my containers
this is simply learn dr. Rob /my node
app - - replicas equal to I want to
replicas to be running and the port that
I want to expose this particular part is
on h0x you know so let me run this as
soon as this is run it creates something
called as an deployment all right now
let me just say I'm not really
interested in the deployment I'm
interested in checking if at all the
ports are up and running so I will say
Cuba CTL get it alright so that was
pretty fast so I have two ports that are
running here these are two replicas
because I asked for two replicas these
ports are running so I can run cube CTL
described pond makeup alright I can pick
up any of the pod name and see what is
the pod what is the information that is
it contained from what is the image that
is pulling what is the image image name
ID this is actually running my pod which
is actually spinning up a container
right so far so good
so incumbent is the pods can are
ephemeral so they can be there at any
time cannot be written down if I need to
expose my pot outside I would have to
create a service for my pot so what I'll
do is I'll create a very very simple
service by exposing this particular on
deployment before that can check give
serial get deployment so as a deployment
is created the deployment name is simply
an app so I will expose my deployment
simply learn a pass yeah I'll just
exposes them you see all right I'm not
specifying what type and all I don't
want to get into the complications of
what are the different types of exposing
this service and all that stuff
so if I don't specify anything it gives
me something process cluster rightly so
this is where my pod is actually exposed
so let me just check if at all this pod
is up and running and just try a simple
curl command ah curl HTTP colon this is
my cluster IP and the port is 80 80 if
at all I hit this it's actually hitting
my application and giving me whatever I
put a simple
sister out kind of a thing where I'm
just printing the container ID of
whatever pod is serving big so lot of so
I'm actually eating my container and I'm
getting this output from the kinase so
everything looks good my containers up
and running so let me just go and clean
it up I will say come CTL delete
deployment
lalana they should get rid of all the
pots that I created you CTL get bought
alright these parts are in terminating
things then just check cheap CTL get
services there's one service I don't
want this service let me delete that
keep CTL deleted service how long this
alright that's good so let me come back
to my host my cops are will from where
I'm running so I managed to successfully
verify this part see if everything is up
and running so what I'll do is I'll just
go ahead and complete this demo by going
and getting rid of my cluster so cops
delete the cluster - Anthony yes alright
so this will ensure that it will clean
up my complete cluster that I created so
I had three or four running instances if
you see that all the three are shutting
down because you know the cop server
which had cops installed on it it's now
got a mandate the cordoned I shut down
and clean up the whole instances and all
those things that are created as a part
of my deployment
thanks to that month finally Matthew is
going to explain some of the most common
interview questions hello and welcome to
kubernetes interview questions now the
great thing about being a kubernetes
expert is that there is a growing market
for people wanting to hire you and
you're gonna get asked a lot of
questions in this video we're gonna take
you through the 13 most common questions
that you are likely to be asked in the
Kuban eighties interview as always if
you like this video we have the
subscribe button below and then the like
button that will notify you of all the
new videos as they get submitted also if
you have any questions feel free to post
those into the questions below and we'll
get back to you with answers with
trained answer as many questions as
possible so without any more hesitation
let's jump into some of the popular
interview questions that you're gonna
get as we're gonna break up the
interview questions into three
categories it's gonna be beginner
intermediate and advanced the beginner
questions are really going to cover
about three-quarters of the questions
that we're going to ask you and then the
intermediate and advanced will finalize
out the will fish out the final quarter
and and the reason is is that quite
typically most interviews you'll be
asked you know intermediate to beginner
level questions mainly beginner level
quest
just so you can demonstrate your
understanding of kubernetes and then
there's always one advanced question
that gets thrown out just to make sure
that you really do know what you're
talking about and you've done at least
one or two kubernetes environment set
ups to be able to validate your
experience so let's kind of jump into
that first section which is you know why
is kubernetes widely used and your
answer to this really comes into the
fact that kubernetes is widely used
because of three distinct areas one is
that kubernetes is an open source
platform that is readily available for
the management of containers and allows
you to manage the deployment scaling and
management of those containers and so
the first areas that it allows you for
easy deployment of your containers the
ability to scale effectively within
communities not just vertically but
horizontally for your containers and
then finally the kubernetes environment
itself was really designed to make it
easy to manage containers in small parts
other key areas of why kubernetes is
popular is that kubernetes is the single
largest open source project out there
since its launch in 2014 is just grown
in leaps and bounds around that project
there is just a huge community both an
online and physical community there are
just a large number of online groups
that are supporting kubernetes and allow
you to get fast access to information
but in addition to that there are also a
lot of local meetup groups that cover
specifically kubernetes whether as part
of a DevOps group or as part of a
dedicated kubernetes group the actual
environment itself is a really robust
way of being able to manage your
containers containers are becoming the
most popular way of being able to deploy
cloud based applications kubernetes is
an effective and persistent storage
environment so kubernetes is also able
to effectively manage persistent storage
whether it's local storage as a SSD
drive or a local hard drive or whether
it's cloud based storage and because of
the way that kubernetes is architecture
it's really designed for the cloud from
the ground up so it's a great way to get
started in building out your cloud
and then finally the actual tools within
kubernetes are designed to help em
manage the health and monitoring of the
environment itself so what is Google
container engine so the Google container
engine is another open source solution
but it's designed for managing the
docket containers and clusters and so
kubernetes is a container management
solution and docker is the most popular
container solution out there and this is
just a way of being able to bring the to
effectively within to each other so that
you can have docker containers manage
the application and then kubernetes
manage the scale of your applications as
they're vertically and horizontally
scaled across your network so what is
difference between kubernetes and docker
and this is important because kubernetes
and often dropped in the same sentence
and there's a lot of people that get
confused between the two so
fundamentally kubernetes is about taking
pods which contain containers which have
applications in and deploying them at
scale across a cloud network docker is
the container solution itself so the
actual application itself is put into
the docker container because of this
difference kubernetes is designed for
auto scaling is highly available whereas
docker simply isn't because it doesn't
have to worry about that within the
container itself the kubernetes
environment will check for liveness and
readiness of the health of the entire
infrastructure whereas with docker is
just really going to check the services
that are coming in and out of the actual
application itself within the container
kubernetes is complicated to set up it
really is just simply complicated set up
and what you'll find is a lot of cloud
services what you do the set up for you
whereas docker is very easy to set up
the as you would expect where the
tolerance ratio there is high fault
tolerance River kubernetes whereas with
docker is low fault tolerance again this
is fundamental in the two different
types of strategy that kubernetes and
Daaga have they're both connected
tightly with each other but they both do
different things so what are the notable
features of kubernetes one is the
ability to do container Bern's
kubernetes always knows where to place a
container within its entire network
within the pods and with this
infrastructure the services are
for security network and storage it is
self-monitoring so it goes in and is
able to check its own nodes for Health
and the containers within the nodes so
it makes sure that the applications are
always running effectively you can do
the scaling effectively both vertically
and horizontally within kubernetes the
solution is open source so there's no
actual fee for the actual kubernetes
service itself and kubernetes allows for
storage orchestration what does they
mean by storage orchestration storage
orchestration is that you are able to
access and share either local storage
such as a hard drive or SSD drive or a
cloud-based drive and my preference is
always to go with cloud-based Drive
because then you are really positioning
your solution to be a true cloud-based
application so what are the main
advantages of kubernetes where you get
automatic rollback for changes that go
wrong the you're able to automate a lot
of the processes that would have been
manual processes previously you're able
to scale the resources both vertically
and horizontally easily and quickly and
then these three areas the role bank or
to making role bank automating services
and be able to scale indirectly allows
you to save money by reducing the amount
of time and people working on your
operations environment so let's break
out the architecture of kubernetes so
you're gonna be explained asked to
explain how is kubernetes architecture
structured and there are three key areas
there's the application layer there's
kubernetes layer and then there's the
infrastructure layer we're gonna start
off with the infrastructure layer and so
the infrastructure layer is our base
layer and this is where all your where
you make your clusters for your
collections of storage and networking
resources within kubernetes and this is
where you would have if your databases
are your data stored locally on a hard
drive or in the cloud your core network
and the VMS that you'd be building out
your infrastructure on these allow you
to group many Sheen's together into a
single unit so that you're able to scale
up and down very easily to meet customer
demand so let's talk about the middle
layer which is the kubernetes layer
so if we're looking at our architecture
for a kubernetes layer it's really
broken down for the the core operating
system the docker container environment
and the kubernetes code itself and this
is where you're able to take machines
and pull them together as a cluster so
that they work within that kubernetes
system you have a master controller
within kubernetes that actually then
we'll go ahead and manage the scheduler
controller manager the API server and
then you'll be able to cluster all of
these communities together so that
they're all working and processing as
one single unit and then finally let's
look at the application layer where you
actually have your apps and so the
application layer where you have your
pool and your services you know
kubernetes will use api to connect in
and out of this layer it's to run your
applications within containers and you
use instructions that are written in
Yama or JSON to actually set up those
containers and you actually have the
environment running on a plan that
examines these instructions so it keeps
the entire environment healthy a VI
ecosystem is used to interact with the
cluster it's so you don't have to do
that by yourself so make sure that
you're referencing that the api's are
secured and connecting in and out of the
system and so you have your schedule and
Control Manager actually from the
kubernetes environment doing the hard
work and then the workers themselves
execute the commands they're coming from
kubernetes so you will be asked to kind
of dig into some of the key areas such
as explaining the master node and
listing its components so the master
node is comprised of four key components
there's the cluster store the controller
manager the scheduler and the API server
so four key point components remember
four fingers four components and then
you're going to be asked to maybe dig
deeper into what is a cluster within
kubernetes and so a customer is really
combination of resources such as
machines that into a single node and
then those nodes are pulled together and
work as a single cluster as a whole
kubernetes will work with that whole
cluster and then once you're actually
working with that whole cluster
if a node fails or needs to be removed
kubernetes is able to do that quickly
and effectively so let's talk a little
bit about what are the different types
of controllers in kubernetes and there
are five types of control manager you
have the node controller the service
account the token control are the
endpoint controller and the replication
controller and so the node controller
controls and handles the node in the
system the service account enables
access controls in the system the token
controller cleans up any tokens for
non-existent service accounts the
endpoint control adjoined services in
pods to the endpoint objects and the
replication controller manages the pod
lifecycle so what is the role of the
cloud controller manager within this
environment and so the role the cloud
control manager is really to help manage
persistent storage and so persistent
storage is storage that's neither local
storage to the physical machine such as
an SSD or hard drive or cloud-based
storage and this allows the storage to
be shared across the entire network what
is the role of the cube API server and
the cube scheduler so the cube API
server is possible for the establishment
communication between the Kuban etting
nodes and the master components and it
does this through the air through api's
the api's themselves are all commands
that are rest-based commands and it
implements an interface which means
different tools and libraries can
communicate effectively with each other
so what is the role of the cube api
server and the cubes scheduler so the
cubes captured actually does the
distribution of work across the entire
infrastructure to the actual llamó
scripts that you've written are executed
appropriately at the right time so
you're gonna be asked to explain
persistent volumes in kubernetes so a
persistent volume is just a place where
you can store data again this can be
local data as in a hard drive local to
the physical machine or it can be
cloud-based data so what is a cube let
and a cube proxy so a couplet is a
service responsible for conveying
information to and from the control plan
it's so the process and the queue proxy
itself is responsible to maintaining the
work and
within the note server in addition every
node in the cluster runs our simple
network proxy and queue proxy routes
request to the correct container in that
node in addition you'll have some basic
and primitive load balancing and
management of the node from the proxy
itself there is additional layers of
management that get done outside of the
proxy but the proxy is also there to
help do some localized load management
so what is cube ctso cube CTL is your
command line or terminal window
interface that allows you to execute
commands and later in this video we'll
actually go through some of those
commands etcd is the store that
configures the details and essential
values such as key value pairs that are
distributed across your entire network
it also manages the network rules and
the post forwarding of activity so what
are the disadvantages of kubernetes well
the first is it's really hard to install
and configure and this is why Asia and
many cloud services such as Google cloud
will actually do the installation and
configuration of kubernetes for you it
does take a long time to get up and
running with kubernetes not so much for
the actual software but your own
experience of being able to use
kubernetes it is not simple to manage
the service you actually have to have a
lot of experience and this is why people
get paid a lot for kubernetes skills
it's a difficult environment to get up
and running and be effective in that
management again kubernetes is just not
an easy platform to learn it takes a lot
of time and effort and one of the
disadvantages is that while kubernetes
itself is free because it is an open
source project getting the people who
are skilled you to using Quba Nettie's
is expensive alright so those were kind
of the introductory questions that you
can expect to be asked in your interview
the next set of questions are really
going to be on an intermediate and
advanced level and these are the
questions that will be thrown out you
know there you see these as being that
the trick questions which are really
there to test that you have the skill
set to be able to implement and manage
communities within a company so what
happens if a master node fails what
happens if a worker node fails
how would kubernetes manage that well
kubernetes is really designed for this
kind of scenario and so you can actually
look at it and the response would be is
that the pod itself does not get
affected kubernetes will actually
respond and fix the the failed node
whether it is needs to be repaired
whether there needs to be restarted or
needs to be replaced so what is a
service role in kubernetes so a service
role is an abstraction for all of the
pods it provides a virtual IP address it
allows clients to connect to containers
running in the pods using that virtual
IP address and the command that you
would use to get that we would use some
of these cubes ETL commands it's quite a
simple one it's cube CTL get services
and you get a full list then of all the
services that are available so how do I
do a role Bank in deployment so there's
a couple of ways you can do the rollback
and the first is if you want to see the
rollouts history deployment you would
write cubes ETL rollout history
deployment and then in square brackets
deployment if you want to just restore
to the previous rollout the command
would be cube CTL rollout undo
deployment and then in square brackets
deployment and that would take you back
to the previous deployment so what is an
ingress Controller
so the ingress controller really is a
pod that manages that inbound traffic
and a prominent feature that traffic is
that it is secured with an SSL
termination and so what we're going to
do to now address some of the key ways
in which you can provide API security
zone Kuban at ease and we have eight of
those so the first four are implementing
tier TLS for your security the second
would be API authentication the third is
to make the Cubist protection the cublas
protected via authorization mode equals
web hook command the fourth is to
monitor RBAC failures the fifth is to
remove those default service account
permissions six would be to filter
egress to cloud API metadata api's the
seventh is to use pod security policy to
restrict container policies and protect
the node and the eight and five
is to keep the cube at the latest
version alright let's go into some of
the more advanced commands and so the
advanced questions you're gonna get are
gonna be commands that you're gonna be
asked to write now my advice for you for
these questions is to make sure that you
have some of these basic commands
memorized they don't have to be perfect
when you're in the interview environment
but it's good to be able to get up to a
whiteboard and actually write out what
these commands are just so you can
actually demonstrate that you know what
the commands are the interview isn't
gonna ask you questions on how would you
apply kubernetes to the company that
you're being hired for because you
simply don't have that knowledge but
they do want to be able to see clearly
that you understand the commands and
terminal window instructions that will
be able to demonstrate how you would
actually go in and access some of that
information so from the first questions
you might be asked is how do you package
kubernetes applications and so you would
use the package manager within cuba
Nettie's to be able to manage the and
configure and deploy applications into
your cluster and so here we have the the
helm command that you would use so what
our init containers and in each
container gets executed for any other
containers can run on the pod and so you
want to be able to illustrate what the
init instructions would look like and
here we have an example and I would
again use this example and maybe
memorize it for when you have this
question come up in your interview so
what is the difference between a config
map and a secret and these are more
fundamental so it config map just has
the instructions that are clearly
available in plane tanks on what the
cube is supposed to do whereas the
secrets are actually encrypted and these
are like passwords and other sensitive
data that you don't want to have easily
available these are encrypted
information have to be decrypted to
access the content so if a node is
tainted is there a way to schedule the
pods to that node and the answer is no
there isn't and so what you have to do
then is schedule the pod to
fixed and so that scheduled applaud to
fix the tainted node to allow for
toleration to that and we have here the
example code that you would use to do
that so how do you deploy a feature with
zero downtime in kubernetes well
kubernetes is designed to be able to
roll out applications with zero downtime
and here we have four examples using the
rolling update as a strategy for zero
downtime deployments in kubernetes again
memorize one of these so you can
actually illustrate how you use rollout
to be able to deploy a zero downtime
solution so how do you monitor a pod
that is always running and so to do that
you'd use the liveness probe to check
the health of the application within the
pod and see whether or not there are any
failures or whether or not the pod
itself needs to be restarted so how do
you drain traffic from pod during a
maintenance so again this is a simple
command for you to remember but to be
able to drain an application so that
it's easy for you to be able to do
maintenance on the application you would
use the cube CTL drain and then in
square brackets the node name and that
would then temporarily drain that
particular pod so you can actually do
maintenance on it what you have to then
and this would probably give you bonus
points with your're in an interview is
then reference to the uncoordinated
itself so that the pod itself can come
back up into life and work as a fully
functioning solution so to be able to
tie services to a partner to a set of
pods so you can apply in labels to the
actual parts themselves and then use the
labels as selectors to be able to glue
services to that pod and again we have
here an example of how you'd actually do
that and again this isn't one of those
where you can pretty one be asked to
write this out but it'd be good to have
this memorized how do you get all pods
on a node and so the following command
will actually go ahead and bring all the
pods into a kubernetes cluster this is
quite a lengthy and you know maybe you
want to like talk to how this would be
done but we have the instructions
how to do that right here and the
important part is to make sure that you
are when you're talking about the node
name that you reference to whoever
you're interviewing that you would what
you would switch out to reference the
actual nodes that you're trying to pull
together into the kubernetes cluster so
how do pods mount NFS volumes and so in
these examples here we actually define
the NFS server and then the port and how
you'd actually mount two together and
again what you want to be able to do is
illustrate why you would use Yammer and
how you'd actually then point to
specific IP addresses within your
kubernetes environment within either the
production or test environments to be
able to illustrate how you would mount
out those NFS volumes with that we'll
reach the end of this company kubernetes
course I hope you enjoyed this video do
like and share it thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
[Music]